when you're climbing up the helicopter
is another one of my favorite moments
because that's what separates these
movies from other movies in another
movie that's a wide shot if the stunt
double he climbs up really fast
they shared under stage yeah the camera
right there and in real time it's just
watching you just kind of get up there
and get that helicopter that pulls back
and it's just watching and I'm just
climbing up yeah was that a hard heart
the first person asked me climbing up
that rope that was hard it was it was
cold you know that's a long rope climb
did you master the rope climb in gym
class like were you that was that no I
was I you know it's it's but it's never
easy it's not like the rope climbs ever
no one's like oh I can do this easy it's
a rope climb man and it's it's hard
you feel like with Tom taking on so much
of these stunts himself that there's
pressure like on the other cast to be
like no I don't want to stunt-double I'm
doing it we all feel like this is what
these films are about you know this this
is what since since he hung off the Burj
Khalifa and I remember being in the
audience the first night I saw it and
the sense of like holy that the audience
emitted when they saw him step off that
building it was like this is key
you know this degree of authenticity the
fact that it's a practical stunt done by
the actor it adds a degree of tension
and exhilaration that you don't get when
it's done by someone else or it's done
in a computer it's a kind of extra
textual element which is really
thrilling and so we all want to be part
of that you know no means so I I'm like
I'm out I'm up for it whatever I
wouldn't do the kind of stuff he does
because he risks his life which is crazy
it doesn't exist today it doesn't it
isn't it isn't you know that there's
that people could dismiss it as crazy
but I think ultimately he's that
committed to his job he cares that much
about delivering in what is a very
crowded marketplace today an authentic
experience for the audience the kind of
sense of wonder and thrill
[Music]
why do you think these movies how do you
think they separate themselves from
other action movies the Mission
Impossible movies what are they bring to
the table that's maybe different from
what you'll see in another action movie
well you know Mission has you know
they're in that sweet spot of that being
number six and and a built in core
audience who loves it were you know
fanatic about it because if you know the
elements that the mission and Tom Cruise
bring to it you know each time out you
know of course with the huge stunts
pieces and the familiarity of the
characters and the friendships
relationships and the things you've come
to expect that iconic opening you know
that that that music those masks you
know so it's a familiarity but also it's
big surprises big surprises every time
they come out and that's why I want one
of my own men on the scene to appraise
the situation
agent Walker special activities his
reputation precedes you use a scalpel I
prefer a hammer my man goes where no one
goes so what's more demanding playing
Superman or starring opposite Tom Cruise
in a Mission Impossible movie oh there
are so many different factors that go
into these roles which no one knows
about so it's tough to answer that I can
say one thing though working with Tom
has been absolutely amazing it's been
such a wonderful opportunity to do these
stunts myself rather than get on to a
movie there I was like oh the actors
don't do the stunts anyway so we're
gonna build this whole thing and then
all right actor step out we'll have the
real man standing and do something cool
I want to do the cool stuff yeah and
this has been a good opportunity for me
to do it it also taught me that you
can't just go off the merits of being a
physical person you've actually got to
build up a full numerous skill sets to
achieve these things motivate license
like stunt driving helicopter license
helicopter stunt flying stunt plane
flying all of these things all these
things at Tom
can do I'm gonna need to up my game and
learn myself being that film is riding a
motorbike without a helmet had on safety
brake for this one challenging shot that
rig just didn't work and we looked at
Tom and said what are we gonna do and he
said
my friends we gotta roll we gotta go we
gotta shoot he he got on his bike and
took off
that is Tom riding the motorcycle
against traffic around the Arc de
Triomphe the ones I feel like in these
movies location is so important because
once you set a location it automatically
becomes a main character in this movie I
love the nooks and crannies of Paris you
know from you know the mountains of New
Zealand or the helices so when do you
set a location what how early does that
happen in the case of this movie before
I ever started writing this really yeah
I had a rough outline of what the movie
was lose some ideas in terms of the
dialogue and the characters I knew what
the opening scene of the movie was but I
was very specific with the studio having
learned on rogue nation I'm not even
going to start writing until I know
where I'm shooting it it's what you end
up doing is you write a scene and then
you're trying to find a location to fit
it and you always end up compromising
either the scene or the location so we
went to Paris and we picked all of those
streets and we went to New Zealand and
picked all of those valleys and nooks
and crannies London we figured out the
foot chase and we worked all of that out
ahead of time knowing where we were
going to shoot because basically what I
tell my location guy he says well I
don't know where this scene is taking
place and I said you find me a place
that looks cool and I'll tell you what's
happening you don't understand what
you're in often
you need to walk away please don't make
me go through you I was so happy when
they said that they wanted her to come
back because I thought she was so good
and such a good character and yes in the
meter world and female strength etc etc
but she was a bloody good human being
today and there was nothing I wanted to
change but I wanted to maintain her
individuality and her balance but not
the good and evil but her constant
standing on the grey line mm-hmm well we
don't know where we have her definitely
between her and Ethan Hunt yeah you know
you don't know is she on his side or is
she not
yeah and that for us all was so
important because I think Ethan needs an
equal to throw him off a bit otherwise
he's just undead Lee isn't he yeah
[Music]
[Music]
what was like the Tom Cruise eeeh
snowmen on set like what's like a fun
Tom Cruise oh it was uh what was it he
was doing Top Gun quotes while we were
flying in formation all the helicopters
when we'd finish doing our New Zealand
Porsche were flying in formation and
sitting there with their headphones on
and Tom started doing Top Gun quotes it
was amazing it was so cool he's on the
helicopter does all of this crazy ask
you beeping by the way don't worry about
it yeah okay he does this but we have
built a hill to replicate a scene in New
Zealand and we're in a 4x4 and it's of
the big the the car thingy I don't I'm
not good with cars I sound like that's
when I say car things and we have to go
down a hill yeah towards the helicopter
yeah yeah uh-huh
and we're having fun and laughing and
Tom's joking and then office and right
before we go he literally kicks in
to Tom Cruise health and safety
department which means there's no joke
and he goes right guys if this tips over
I want everyone to get this embracement
we go down Rebecca come yet whoops I
come up like this and a funny thing that
that resembles is it doesn't matter how
big or small the stunt is for him
everything is just so important and then
he jumps into laughing again yeah you
know you had said that in order to
direct the second mission movie you
wanted it to look like as if it came
from a different director visually and
I'm curious to know what were some of
your inspirations kind of coming into
this movie in terms of achieving that
well the biggest thing was to not you
know it was to not pursue so much
specific inspirations I mean rogue
nation I had I had very specific
inspirations that I was that I was
tapping into and then I was liberally
referencing inside jokes and Easter eggs
and in this movie we Rob Hardy and I
didn't do that so much Rob is a big
lover of John Carpenter's The Thing and
point blank was a movie that he showed
me John Boorman's point blank was a
movie he came to me with early on and I
made one little reference to point blank
as kind of a wink to rob but everything
else was we we discovered after the fact
we went back in there there's the fight
scene the gunfight that happens in
London when we started looking at the
dailies we were like my god this looks
like how contrasting point-blank but we
hadn't we weren't specifically reaching
for that when we did it it was more of
an inspiration than an influence
there are nods to an influence than an
inspiration there are not so the other
films though in there very good you're
not in which I thought was interesting
and you know did you have certain scenes
that you wanted to peel well I only had
one nod to the - mission one I think you
know the one I'm talking yeah and
everything else I've heard other people
picking things out as references to the
other films which I didn't really think
of at the time but I can see I can see
how they look like references to either
their films so I'm it's it's all just
mission being mission I think accepted
either you've lost this one was done
this time
what's done is done when we say it's
done I was just gonna ask you about the
longevity of the series and whether or
not these movies and when you're
finished with them or if you're open to
like James Bond defying it and having
other people play yeah I mean it would
be interesting to see what happens to
see what an audience you know I I would
never ask anyone I've the kind of stuff
that I've done is been things that I've
cultivated and to have someone to say
you have to do this that's that's like
now I don't know if I could ask anyone
to do that even if they would want to do
it and people think they want to do it
but once they start kind of doing it
they realize how challenging it is and
it's it's also look it's I've been doing
this since I was a little kid doing
stuff like this and I've been really
working on a1 systems on how to make it
so that you can actually survive these
things and create those so it's
something of course my whole idea was
that the franchise would always go on
but I just you know maybe nice you know
I hope you bake like seven more I said
you wouldn't bother me you'll be both
and then oh then I'll be like okay
[Music]
what are you waiting for I'm jumping out
a window oh sorry
good luck
[Music]
you